the the United States is the most
refrigerated country in the world we
have more than a hundred million cubic
meters of thermal control that means
nothing to me but once I did the math
and that is actually not so much smaller
than the Arctic so basically we built a
third Pole for our food to live in which
is incredible and then you know all
these separate refrigerated spaces are
connected by a cold chain so you end up
with this sort of seamless you know
monument of engineered winter and the
thing that happened to me is that I
realize I've been writing about food for
a decade at this point when I first sort
of turned my attention to the cold chain
and and I realized I had visited farms
and I had visited factories and
obviously I'd talked to chefs and I had
I'd even been to the grocery store on
occasion but I had never been inside a
refrigerated warehouse and I'm gonna
guess most of you haven't either
and here we are in the Bay Area which
you know home of farm-to-table but that
to word it goes via the refrigerated
warehouse like in between farm and table
is a giant cold space that nobody thinks
about so I decided to explore it and
first of all I partnered with the Center
for land use interpretation which those
of you haven't heard of it you are in
for a treat when you google it later but
we mapped the american cryosphere and
and then I still wasn't done so then I
wrote a piece for the New York Times
magazine that took me to China to
explore their artificial cryosphere and
then I still wasn't done so then I
decided to sell a book on this topic and
and research that and write that and
that is still not done but that's that's
a whole other story
but yes so I have gone deep into this
artificial quite a cryosphere and my
goal tonight is say let's go on a quick
spin through this space past present
future and I have so I hope you wrapped
up warmly we are stepping inside and I
want to start this thing right with a
banquet this in its time was the most
talked about meal in the United States
the organizers had originally booked
quite a small room they had to upgrade
to the largest banqueting-hall in
Chicago the guest list kept expanding a
member of Congress decided they wanted
to come then other members of Congress
decided they wanted to come people were
were flooding this and and so what is so
special about this meal you ask yourself
well this was the world's first cold
storage banquet everything on the menu
had been stored under refrigeration so
except I should point out for the olives
in the dry martini not refrigerated so
this is tech mystic place on Monday
October 23rd 1911 and there's a there's
you know thousand people in the room
white linen you know full table service
the crystal out the the result was two
hours of what industry Journal the egg
reporter called unalloyed pleasure and
what is amazing about it is that
everything on the menu had spent at
least six months and up to a year in
cold storage and and what I love about
this menu too is and again you know here
in the Bay Area we
are used to seeing who grew our you know
this is Mary's chicken or this is like
this particular heirloom variety of
tomato do we ever see what cold storage
it was in we do not here we have booths
cold storage crowd you know the last
address of that salmon and and so the
that was that was sort of and the sort
of introduction to the mail explained
well your turkey that's eleven months
old your eggs seven months the the
president of the natural national
poultry butter and egg association who
was kind of giving this introduction set
your cap on received its summons to the
great unknown last Valentine Day the the
pie even the pike old stored flour
butter turned in June apples and this is
October so they they could have had
fresh but no they'd been in storage
alongside the salmon at booths for a
year the head chef of the hotel where
this was being served said man called
Lucia there has never been a better meal
served at this hotel
the San Antonio reporter expressed
whatever the journalists from there said
nothing was quite fresh the the poultry
men the president the poultry Mon
Association said this is edible proof
that cold stored foods are not only good
they're better than the ones that you
would eat fresh and the congressman who
was called upon to sort of speak agreed
and said yes I really believed that
there is more flavor to cold storage
poultry than the kind that is advertised
as freshly killed and he said I'm going
back to Washington I'm telling the folks
cold storage is where it's at so this
this this kind of lunch became a
national trend so la held the next one
then there was one in Detroit there was
one in Philly
years later there was another one in
Chicago with literally thousands of
people and a special three-page souvenir
brochure with not only where the food
had been stored but also the temperature
and relative humidity were to be stored
so it became a trend and and this is
barely more than a century ago
[Music]